Hi, welcome. There are two confessions I
want to start this session with. One is
I'm a dabler. I'm an expert in very
little, but I'm interested in a lot of
different things. The second is I like
to write. It's true. I like to write to
be read, but I also like to write when
I'm confused, when I have a question to
which I don't have the answer, because I
think the practice of writing about
something and reasoning your way through
is the way to find an answer.
So that's uh the preamble to what I'm
going to say next.
I teach two classes at the NYU Stern
School of Business. One is a corporate
finance class, the other is a valuation
class. And about 25 years ago, and I've
taught this for 40 years, these two
classes for for 40 years. But about 25
years ago, towards the end of the 1990s,
the head of my department came to me and
said, "We have a new class. We'd like
you to run it." And I said, "Run it? I
mean, what does that mean? I usually
teach classes. He said, "Well, you don't
have to teach this class because it's a
class composed entirely of outside
speakers." And the outside speakers were
going to be successful investors,
investors who would succeed in the
market. Now, being in New York gave me
an advantage then because so many
successful investors lived or worked in
New York. So, I went about coming up
with a list of speakers I would have for
the class. And I came to my first
realization. There are very few
successful investors. You're saying
that's not true. I see successful
investors of all the time. It's true.
You can succeed in a year, even two
years or 5 years, but most of the time
that success comes from luck. But you
look at investors who've succeeded over
the long term. There are relatively few
of them. So that's the first
recognition. Most people who tried to
beat markets don't, but there are a few
who do. Now the second realization I
came to as I went down that list of
people who' succeeded over the long term
is they came from entirely different
sets of the investing spectrum. Some
were value investors. Think of Warren
Buffett. Some were growth investors.
Some were traders. So actually a
technical analyst/chartist would have
been successful over the long term. So
the second recognition I came to is
there's no one path to success. There
are multiple ways in which people have
have been successful in markets and they
bring in very different views on how
markets work or don't work so they can
take advantage of them. The third
recognition I came to as I talked to
each of these speakers because I got a
chance to talk to them for 20 or 30
minutes before each class and after the
class was they even though they were
very different in their views on markets
each of them had a core philosophy that
was theirs that they believed in. Now
when I mean when I talk about philosophy
I'm not talking about a strategy. Buying
a low PE ratio is a strategy but having
a view of why markets might underpric
companies low PE ratios is a philosophy
very different philosophy but each of
them had a philosophy a well that they
could go back to when a strategy stopped
working. So after the class was done and
thank God I taught it only once
I started putting things on down on
paper and from that was born one of my
books the investment philosophies book
published by John Wy and this book is
not about finding the best investment
philosophy because I don't believe there
is one it's about describing different
philosophies I start with technical
analysis and charting often we give them
short shift in investing classes value
investing growth investing market timing
arbitrage Mark. So essentially looking
across the spectrum and with each one
here's what I tried to do. I look at the
strategies that come out of the
philosophy but more critically I think
about the makeup the psychological
makeup and the capital and the other
characteristics you need as an investor
would succeed with each one. Why am I
doing that? Because most people who try
to imitate these successful investors
don't succeed. Right? Think of the
hundreds of books on Warren Buffett.
Then ask yourself, how many other people
have the returns that Warren Buffett had
over the long term? Very few. There's
many a slip between the cup and the lip,
which means that there you can try to
imitate an investor, but if you don't
have the personal makeup to pull it off,
it's not going to succeed. So, what is
this book about? It's a book about
describing philosophies, but more
critically, if you're the reader, it's a
book about you finding your best
investment philosophy. Which one will
that be? It depends on who you are, how
much capital you bring to the game, why
you invest, and what your psychological
makeup is. That first edition came out
about 20 years ago. I updated to a
second edition about a decade ago, and I
just finished the third edition. You're
saying, why do you need new editions?
It's not like investing becomes new and
different. It's true. Much of investing
stays the same. Much of what we see,
we've seen before, but there are new
things that happen in markets that give
rise to new philosophies. For instance,
in the last decade, you've seen the rise
of a crypto trader. People who trade
Bitcoin who become very wealthy trading
Bitcoin. Who am I to say that's not a
good philosophy?
I actually p did not pay enough
attention to gold and collectibles in
the first edition. And there are people
out there who succeed investing in
golden collectibles. It might not be for
me, but it works for them. So with each
edition, I've tried to bring in
philosophies that I've either paid not
enough attention to, but are newer
philosophies. And in the third edition,
as I said, I brought a chapter in on
alternative investing, which includes
cryptos, gold, collectibles,
because that is a philosophy that some
people adear to.
I hope you get a chance to try this book
out. Not so much because my writing is
brilliant and pathbreaking. It's not.
But maybe it can give you a way of
finding the right philosophy for you. If
you can accomplish that, my job is done.
Because in a sense, once you have that
core philosophy, you will be able to
come up with strategies come out of that
philosophy.
I hope you found the session useful and
I hope you get a chance to give this
book a try. Thank you very much for
listening.